schupps mich und du fängst dir eine
kugel so drohte ein polizist während
einer demo in dresden einem
demonstranten wie es zu der eskalation
kommen konnte das zeigen wir ihnen jetzt
unfassbare worte bei einer demonstration
für mehr flüchtlings aufnahmen in
dresden
anhänger der usa dresden der
undogmatischen radikalen antifa stehen
dicht an dicht mit einem polizisten
es wird gedrängelt der polizist reagiert
shops mich unten fans die ihnen kugel
empörte rufe schein aus den reihen der
demonstranten
der beamte weicht zurück greift sogar
zur dienstwaffe sind zwei aspekte die
kritische bis zum einen dass der kollege
die hand auf der waffe hatte was man auf
dem video nicht sieht war das aus der
versammlung heraus nebel topf geworfen
wurde der kollege wollte den rest
beweismittel sicherstellen dass bedrängt
worden von 25 kommunen hat sich
zurückgezogen und beim rückte nehmen die
hand auf die wache gemacht das
entspricht genau dem ausbildungsstand
und ist okay der satz der ebenfalls in
kritik steht ist ein bisschen anders hat
der kollege eingeräumt hat das so gesagt
ist so gefallen
da auch darf nicht passieren keine frage
allerdings muss man hier bei der
bewertung auch die umstände es war
hektisch das war es ein innerer misrata
angespannt berücksichtigen sodass wir
keinen anders sehen deswegen dieses
praktische schritte einzuleiten und bild
reporter thomas fischer ist mir jetzt
live zugeschaltet guten morgen thomas
guten morgen was es denn vor dem video
passiert es gab zuvor eine spontandemo
von einer dresdner gruppe seebrücke die
haben friedlich für die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen demonstriert aus moriya und
aus anderen flüchtlingslagern in
griechenland und die demonstration war
dann soweit beendet bis es dann zu
dieser eskalation haben woraus sich dann
diese gruppe der antifa gebildet hat das
waren etwa 25 mann
und was ist jetzt mit dem polizisten
wurde er jetzt von seinem dienst
suspendiert oder bekommt er jetzt ein
verfahren
nein der polizist hat sich entschuldigt
wie der polizeisprecher sagte
damit ist die sache jetzt erstmal auch
erledigt die staatsanwaltschaft mit er
habe ich gerade eben telefoniert sie
sagt es handelt sich hier um einen akt
der notwehr es gibt also keinen
anfangsverdacht für eine bedrohung oder
für eine straftat
es verhält sich halt so der polizist hat
halt den demonstranten aufgezeigt was
drohen könnte wenn er angreift lich wird
es ist da nicht dazu gekommen
die worte waren zwar recht unorthodox
aber es ist nicht mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren